RESPONSE IS A VERY LOUD
RESPONSE.
WE HAVEN’T RECEIVED ANY
>> Bill: CHRIS WALLACE, GOOD
MORNING ON A FRIDAY.
16 DAYS.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE A COMMENT
ABOUT THIS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THIS
INDICATES ABOUT WHAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION’S PRIORITIES
ARE, CHRIS?
>> WELL, I DON’T KNOW ABOUT
PRIORITIES.
IT DOESN’T SEEM THEY HAVE MUCH
OF AN ANSWER TO THE CRISIS AT
THE BORDER.
MAYBE THAT’S THE REASON THAT
THEY ARE NOT PUSHING IT.
AND YOU KNOW IT’S SO
INTERESTING.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT FIRST SAID
HE WAS PUT KAMALA HARRIS, HIS
VICE PRESIDENT, IN CHARGE OF
THE BORDER THE SENSE WAS HE WAS
PUTTING HER IN CHARGE OF THE
BORDER, THE WHOLE ISSUE.
THEN A DAY OR SO LATER THE
CLARIFICATION CAME SHE IS NOT
IN CHARGE OF THE BORDER, SHE IS
IN CHARGE OF DIPLOMACY WITH
MEXICO AND WITH THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE COUNTRIES TO TRY TO
STEM THE FLOW TO THE BORDER.
SHE HAS HAD A COUPLE OF PHONE
CALLS WITH TOP OFFICIALS IN
THOSE COUNTRIES BUT SHE HASN’T
GONE TO THE BORDER AND SHE
HASN’T GONE TO THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE AND SHE HASN’T GONE TO
MEXICO, WHICH KIND OF MAKES YOU
WONDER WHETHER SHE KNOWS THIS
IS A MESS AND DOESN’T WANT HER
FINGERPRINTS ON IT.
>> Dana: I WONDER IF IT’S THAT
OR I WONDER ALSO IF THEY THINK
IF THEY ARE GOING WOULD JUST
SOLIDIFY IN EVERYBODY’S MIND IT
IS THE CRISIS THAT PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN CLAMORING ABOUT, NOT JUST
A CHALLENGE?
>> AT A CERTAIN POINT I SUPPOSE
MAYBE A MONTH OR SO AGO YOU
COULD PLAY THIS GAME WELL, IT
IS NOT A CRISIS, IT IS A
CHALLENGE.
BUT WHEN YOU SEE THESE VIDEOS
THAT YOU HAVE JUST SHOWN OF THE
KIDS BEING DROPPED FROM THE
WALL OR THAT LITTLE BOY
DESERTED IN THE DESERT OR MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE TREMENDOUS AND
TERRIBLE OVERCROWDING OF CBP
FACILITIES, 20,000 PEOPLE IN
FEDERAL CUSTODY, 172,000 BORDER
STOPS IN THE MONTH OF MARCH
WE’RE WAY PAST THE POINT WHERE
YOU CAN EVEN PRETEND THIS ISN’T
A CRISIS.
IT IS.
IT’S AN IMMIGRATION NATIONAL
SOVEREIGNTY CRISIS.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO ABOUT IT?
>> Bill: HERE IS JOE BIDEN IN
THE ROSE GARDEN AT THE WHITE
HOUSE ON GUN PROPOSALS HE IS
NOW PUTTING FORWARD.
GIVE IT A LISTEN.
>> President Biden: NOTHING --
NOTHING I’M ABOUT TO RECOMMEND
IN ANY WAY IMPINGES ON THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
THEY ARE PHONY ARGUMENTS.
THE IDEA IS JUST BIZARRE TO
SUGGEST THAT SOME OF THE THINGS
WE’RE RECOMMENDING ARE CONTRARY
TO THE CONSTITUTION.
GUN VIOLENCE IN THIS COUNTRY IS
AN EPIDEMIC.
LET ME SAY IT AGAIN.
GUN VIOLENCE IN THIS COUNTRY IS
AN EPIDEMIC AND IT IS AN
INTERNATIONAL EMBARRASSMENT.
>> Bill: DO YOU THINK HIS
PROPOSALS GO ANYWHERE?
MAYBE THAT’S THE RIGHT QUESTION
NOW.
>> WELL, IN TERMS OF HIS
EXECUTIVE ORDERS, YEAH, THOSE
GO INTO EFFECT, REGULATION OF
GHOST GUNS, CALLING ON --
THEY’RE NOT EVEN ACTUALLY
SUBMITTING LEGISLATION ON RED
FLAG.
WE TAKE AWAY A GUN FROM
SOMEBODY ADJUDICATED TO BE A
DANGER TO THEMSELVES OR OTHERS.
THEY’RE SIMPLY SAYING TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WRITE THE
LEGISLATION.
SO THE EXECUTIVE ORDERS GO AS
FAR AS THEY DO BUT THEY
CERTAINLY AREN’T GOING TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM.
IT IS THE SECOND AMENDMENT TO
THE CONSTITUTION, THE RIGHT TO
BEAR ARMS.
I THINK QUITE RIGHTLY YOU
SHOULD HAVE TO IF YOU ARE GOING
TO IN ANY WAY LIMIT IT DO IT
THROUGH LEGISLATION NOT
EXECUTIVE FIAT.
THE PRESIDENT DOESN’T HAVE THE
VOTES.
I DON’T KNOW IF HE HAS 50
DEMOCRATIC VOTES BUT CERTAINLY
DOESN’T HAVE 10 REPUBLICAN
VOTES TO BREAK A FILIBUSTER
WITH THE 60-VOTE MARGIN.
WE’VE SEEN THIS MOVIE BEFORE,
BILL.
TERRIBLE INCIDENCES OF BLOOD
SHED JUST THIS WEEK IN SOUTH
CAROLINA AND TEXAS.
EVERYBODY TALKING ABOUT WHAT
CAN WE DO ABOUT IT?
HUFFING AND PUFFING ON ALL
SIDES OF THE ISSUE AND I THINK
THERE IS GOOD FAITH ON BOTH THE
SIDE OF MORE GUN CONTROL AND
THE SIDE OF TRYING TO PROTECT
OUR SECOND AMENDMENT BUT WE
NEVER SEEM TO BE ABLE TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM.
I DON’T HAVE ANY INDICATION THE
MOVIE WILL END ANY DIFFERENTLY
THIS TIME.
>> Bill: QUICKLY ON SUNDAY.
GO AHEAD.
>> Dana: WHAT DO YOU HAVE
COMING UP THIS WEEKEND?
>> WE HAVE THE PERFECT GUEST TO
TALK ABOUT BOTH GUNS AND THE
BORDER.
INTERVIEW WITH THE GOVERNOR OF
TEXAS, GREG ABBOTT.
HE IS ON THE FRONT LINES ON
BOTH OF THESE ISSUES.
WE’LL ALSO TALK TO HIM ABOUT
COVID BECAUSE TEXAS HAS TAKEN
AN INTERESTING APPROACH.
LIFTED A LOT OF MANDATES ON
MASKS AND LIMITING PEOPLE
COMING IN.
THEY HAD A FULL HOUSE FOR THE
TEXAS RANGERS OPENING DAY AND
DOING PRETTY WELL.
MAYBE THEY KNOW SOMETHING WE
DON’T.
WE’LL TALK TO THE GOVERNOR.
INFRASTRUCTURE WE TALK TO THE
SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION
PETE BUTTIGIEG.
WHAT IS INFRASTRUCTURE, HOW DO
YOU PAY FOR IT AND THE NUMBER
TWO REPUBLICAN IN THE SENATE
JOHN THUNE WHO HAS DIFFERENT
VIEWS.
OUR LEAD GUEST THE GOVERNOR OF